it's kind of cool to go through
the whole process minus the the 1500
panic attacks i've had throughout
and this was your first time directing
like anything yes and there's a movie
like what yeah that's that's kind of a
daunting thing to help okay i had a lot
of help and i i
made you know and i came up with the
system that worked especially when i was
like uh
gonna be on camera on a scene
so like i i i mean actually being an
actor helped
because i hate when you if you do a
scene and after the first take the
director's already out there going you
miss this beat and this and make this
blah blah and then you do another one
and then they come out again by the time
the third take you like nose blind like
i don't even know what this [ __ ]
thing is about so
we came up with this thing i i was
joking with everybody that i was like
you gotta let the horses run you gotta
let the horses run you gotta do three
takes of this thing
because everybody knows what they're
doing as far as actors but it's like i
don't know what you're gonna do so i got
okay you know okay so he's bringing that
i got i gotta have time to take in what
you're doing
and and you taking what i'm doing and
then after i found after like three was
the magic number as usual that it would
start to to get legs and then you could
start to guide it
and then um and then how you give notes
is the way you don't come in saying
you're not doing this you come in
positive you say okay that was great we
got that because
we got that is great when somebody's
completely the opposite okay we have
that version
yeah
but all the seasoned actors knew they
were all like going like oh you see
[ __ ] hated that i was like no no no
it's just i need as many dude i'm gonna
be in the edit room i need as many
options as i can but like uh that was
always hard when he had a seasoned vet
can you try it this way and they would
be like well that means you're not gonna
use the other one and i'm just like can
you just [ __ ]
should you directed it but you also
acted in it yeah
what's that like stupid
it was a stupid move how long were you
filming for it was but it but we it was
weird for like a week and a half and
then we had the system down and then
everybody just gelled and it was a uh it
was a really fun set everybody had a
good time
and then i just kept getting food trucks
to keep just keeping everybody happy
um is the way to go which is great when
you grow up in like a volatile
environment you learn how to keep people
chill yeah how those sort of
levels yeah helps out or you know
so yeah that's kind of what we did and i
think uh
yeah we're dealing with [ __ ] right now
that i'm gonna have to go deal with
that's cool so this is a nice break for
you to not look at the screen for a
while
yeah
was that how it is
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]